hello there my name is Dennis I work at
dice in Stockholm on Star Wars
Battlefront 2 I'm really happy and
excited to be here today so thank you so
much for hanging out with me for a
little bit so we launched our games in
November of last year and clearly we
didn't get it quite right so instead of
coming out of the gate sprinting like we
really wanted to we had to take a step
back and make sure that we were
delivering the game that our players
really wanted so we decided to
completely overhaul our progression
system and add a bunch of new character
cosmetics for players to collect instead
so from there we added a new hunt mode
inspired by the original battlefront
games that I loved personally starting
with the Ewoks on Endor and thank you we
it turn out to be by far the most
popular update of the game and the team
loved building Ewok hunt so as you might
know we're currently in our Han Solo
season with content from the movie
coming next week it's headlined by the
new planet Kessel a really dangerous
place and it features the return of one
of our favorite modes extraction so
looking forward a little bit this summer
we will be introducing a new squad
system to the game which will allow you
to team up much easier and play with
your friends we're also adding a new
star fighter mode focused around
dogfighting with your hero ships and
looking ahead a little bit more we will
also be delivering a new large-scale
multiplayer sandbox experience to focus
around capturing command posts and
attacking and taking out capital ships
but that's not all
we know that you have been asking for
new heroes villains and planets from a
certain era that features a very iconic
Star Wars conflict so I'm excited to
confirm that battlefront 2 this year
we'll be going deep into the Clone Wars
it's only fitting that we begin on the
planet Geonosis featuring multiple
levels including the largest level we
have ever built for battlefront so let's
talk about the heroes and villains first
let me introduce the most powerful droid
the leader of the most powerful droid
army in the galaxy general grievous and
yes he will be going up against my own
personal favorites Jedi Master obi-wan
Kenobi finally making its debut in
Battlefront after all these years so but
we're not done that's not it they will
not come alone joining them is the Dark
Lord and leader of the separatist
alliance Count Dooku
as well as someone to bring balance to
the force
Obi Wan's unruly padawan Anakin
Skywalker the team at home is extremely
excited to be building all of these cool
things EA and dice are committed to
battlefront we had a rough start but I
really think that this game has a bright
future thank you very much for playing
the game providing us with your feedback
talking to us together we will make this
the greatest game that we can possibly
build there would be no battlefront
without you so thank you may the force
be with you and enjoy the rest of a3
thanks
you